foreign
[Music]
ERS all the way from Colorado today I'm
Craig album man on the street in a home
at Airbnb I hope they're okay with me
filming here though they don't know I
have a YouTube channel anyways guys
joining me all the way from Los Angeles
California is a man who is just at a big
five store I called him up because he
has to get on a flight to Colorado to
attend my wedding in a couple of hours
but this takes precedence over all of it
that's right John Humphrey how's it
going I'm I'm excellent sir I'm really
happy to be here thank you for having me
I'm excited to talk about this
incredible breaking news
well before we do that ladies and
Gentlemen even though a sad piece of
news leave a like I really feel like I'm
a reporter standing in everything right
now or I'm like doing some type of like
Junior High project can we get the
weather forecast for Colorado so I know
when I go back to some terrible green
screen behind me but anyway uh yeah this
video is going to be as raw as it gets
because like I said John has a flight to
catch but it's important that we are
both here still gotta put guys if you
haven't heard the news I was on
Instagram and I was like holy crap I
can't believe this is real um because I
thought out of anything they would they
would try to at least keep him but Henry
Cavill he's made it official himself he
will not be returning as Superman and
James Gunn has also acknowledged this so
we got to go over what Henry Cavill put
out and then we're going to go over what
James Gunn put out and uh it's gonna be
a real raw opinion piece but here it is
um I have just had a meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Safran and it's sad news
everyone I will after all not be
returning as Superman I was so like when
I first read this I was like this is
shock and [ __ ] uh after being told by
the studio to announce my return back in
October prior to that higher they're
higher this news isn't the easiest but
that's life uh The Changing of the Guard
is something that happens I respect that
James and Peter have a universe to build
I you know what I just realized I never
read past those first few sentences
until right now I wish them all involved
with the newest Universe the best of
luck and the happiest of Fortunes uh
yeah yeah I mean I'm sure there's still
some a slight bit of bitterness here for
those who've been by my side through the
years we can mourn for a bit but then we
must remember Superman is still around
everything he stands for still exists
and the examples he sets for us are
still there my turn to where the cape
has passed but what Superman stands for
never will it's been a fun ride with you
all onwards and upwards I mean like it
sounds like this is the first time he's
truly this is the first ever official
official thing and even in all the
debating that's ever happened with the
Snyder verse and the Transitions and
like reports are coming out that Henry
cavill's fired and he's like I don't
know if I'm exactly fired and this is
the first time ever where Henry Cavill
is like no I it's official I'm I'm
officially done like and I'm putting it
out there to the public it's not it's
not going to happen so before we go into
James Gunn had a safe job what do you
think
great news Greg loving what we're
hearing out of this it's kind of funny
right John yes I mean it it is in the
saddest kind of way because I mean yeah
this had to have been like the most
heart-wrenching you know it just makes
you feel real bad for the guy like he
had to go out there after yeah and and
confirming like the studio was like yes
confirm your return in October like
especially knowing that was you know
like a team effort uh yeah it's it's
really sad to know that they will have
it's both sad for him and also you know
it adds to the Whiplash of everyone's
confusion after Black Adam I'm sure
again for the people who don't follow
this news religiously so you know I I
it's true yeah now that you bring that
up it's making me wonder like what's
Dwayne Johnson gonna say you know like
are they really gonna cam Black Adam now
anything's possible anything's possible
the other way around it's like the
Snyder verse was like Wow anything's
possible and now with this especially
Henry Cavill and Batgirl and stuff like
that now it's like oh wow anything's
possible and I'm excited to see who they
pick but also I mean I think this is
definitely going to leave a bitter taste
in certain folks mouths and I can't
really blame anybody or take that from
them you know if you loved Henry
cavill's take no this is uh this you
know how excited we were both like super
excited about Henry Cavill returning
like it was one of those arguably the
best part about black Canada
and it's been such like an up and down
like it's it's been one of those
relationships where you just feel like
you're an on and off again thing with
Henry Cavill but we got to go over James
gun said because he does have some big
reveals in here and you got a flight to
catch so uh James Scott said uh Peter
and I have a DC slate ready to go you
know what's funny when you read James
Gunn tweets you forget how his voice
actually sounds like a total like bro
you know like Peter and I have a DC
slate ready to go which we couldn't be
more over the boot about we'll be able
to share some exciting information about
our first project at the beginning of
the new year thank God that means we'll
I'll be back in Los Angeles
yes and it's among those among those on
the Slate is Superman and the initial
stages our story will be focusing on an
earlier part of Superman's life so the
character will not be played by Henry
Cavill and there's the confirmation it's
going to be a new Superman movie but we
just had a great meeting with Henry and
we're big fans and we talked about a
number of exciting possibilities to work
together in the future someone says
please tell me this is a this isn't An
Origin movie no way
and uh could bet Affleck direct met with
Ben yesterday precisely because he wants
to direct and we want him to direct we
just have to find the right project blah
blah blah he's answering some questions
playing nice now look now look I gotta
admit I gotta admit that
it's just kind of funny to me because
I feel like I I was here's why I was
under the impression James Gunn was all
on board for Man of Steel and and for
that side of Henry Cavill because the
guy produced breitburn and breitburn was
so much sort of like
aping off I I it wasn't a parody of Man
of Steel it was if anything kind of just
going down an ALT Universe route of Man
of Steel but it seemed to have so much
motifs that lady I know he didn't direct
the film and
it just seems like yeah you know he put
out that statement a while ago that was
about you know
um the the whole thing of we understand
there's going to be some transitions
there's going to be some we're not going
to keep everyone happy but he must have
seen just how over the moon people were
about Henry Cavill returning but if it
is to reshape the right DC Universe it's
like all right I I guess we'll hold out
hope here and it's like
to then come forward with a
like hey Henry cavill's out
well we got a new Superman movie coming
up just like ooh weird timing to do that
like it feels it's a little strange to
me
because I don't really I'm sure there's
that sounds like hooray new Superman
movie
um it just felt like maybe
it's like when I you know I follow the
Chili Peppers quite religiously and and
they had a guitar player who took over
for John fruscianti Joshua and then with
Josh Klingon offer and then when he when
when they fired Josh it was like
apparently really sad but like five
minutes later they were like jumper
chance he's back that's kind of it's a
bit of a vibe that I have here is like
oh man don't even give us time to say
bye here you know yeah it is yeah it
makes me wonder who's in charge of this
timing and who's order all these things
are going out on because on the one hand
it seems like James Gunn has been in a
very much a position to respond to
things as they happen even Patty Jenkins
put out that statement the other day and
he you know at least made a follow-up
tweet about that uh I I am very curious
as to what becomes of this too because
yeah you're absolutely right I feel like
certain people are gonna March into the
James Gunn Superman iteration with some
kind of Vendetta or bitterness or chip
on their shoulder just given the
Whiplash of this and yeah having it be
sort of so blunt and especially around
the holidays it's kind of just a weird
sort of human timing for all of this uh
what gives me hope is the idea that
again like Patty Jenkins doesn't seem
like it's a 100 like it's not happening
it's just not happening in this current
iteration and hearing that maybe they'll
recast Jason Momoa is lobo and hearing
that they want Ben Affleck to be
involved and they want Henry cow like I
understand that's an easy thing to say
or even lie about but part of me is like
well who knows I mean maybe there is
some other place that we hadn't thought
of that Henry Cavill could pop up in
this universe that would be really cool
uh and maybe down the line there will be
some kind of else worlds means of still
paying homage to his character but
there's no way that this isn't somewhat
of a of a bummer and I just I guess I I
feel for James Gunn because again I
don't know what he has to announce
because of the studio and what he's just
taking it upon himself to announce but
he does seem to exercise a good amount
of restraint and diplomacy which is good
which you know all this stuff with Henry
Cavill has been a sign of shaky
leadership because you know there are
all sorts I don't know it's true there
are all sorts of rumors about like well
Dwayne Johnson and his team kind of
strong-armed Warners into doing what
they wanted and Warner's already had
their own other plan and so
yeah I I don't know what uh to make of
the array as it stands but this suggests
to me that James Gunn and Peter saffron
will hopefully lead with a certain
amount of steadiness
yeah yeah and maybe Liam Hemsworth will
get fired and then he can go back to the
wizard and everyone will be happy next
week they'll announce that Henry Cavill
is back on the way
all right John you got a flight to catch
and uh we had to talk about this but I
mean I'm bummed but we'll I mean I don't
know at this point
it is that thing where you're just in a
relationship for so long that's so cute
you're just like it doesn't matter what
you throw at me now I'm just not I'm not
I'm not even as affected as I once was
six months ago just go be happy we've
been here I'm used to I I'm numb now I'm
numb to what you throw at me
we just both deserve happiness don't we
just let it die all right all right guys
leave your thoughts down below
um man yeah that's a real shocker holy
[ __ ] it's a bummer but we'll talk with
you all soon
[Music]